hello and good morning one of the UK's
leading doctors has said that the NHS is
under more pressure now than during the
peak of the pandemic Sky News
understands that at least six Hospital
trusts are currently dealing with
critical incidents which means they
can't function as usual and almost half
say they're struggling to cope the vice
president of the Royal College of
emergency medicine that's Dr Ian
higginson told Sky News that the
government needs to take urgent action
no doubt whatsoever that
um hundreds of patients are dying
unnecessarily every week because of
what's going on in the Urgent and
Emergency Care sector so several hundred
patients and those are all human beings
these are more than just statistics and
I think we have to be honest about that
I think across all four nations so in
England Scotland where's Northern
Ireland the pressures at throughout the
NHS are unsustainable and they are now
not offering any sort of standard of
care that we were deemed to be
acceptable so when you do something
urgently about this and I think the
first thing we need is a recognition of
the state that the NHS and social care
finds itself in and I think that's where
we need to have a major incident so
there's a recognition from all four
governments that this is a situation
that patients and NHS staff are finding
themselves in
for joining us for more on this is
Malena Vaseline of each Mileena good
morning to you so just talk us through
what kind of pressures the NHS is facing
good morning Kamali well we've heard
about pressures on the energies pretty
much every single winter but we've never
quite heard warnings like these the head
of the Royal College of emergency
medicine saying that 500 up to 500
people could be dying each week because
of the lack of access to Emergency Care
Now another uh Health official within
the NHS said that there should be a
national critical incident declared
which means that all four nations could
coordinate to get this response right in
fact several of the health trusts have
already declared this uh critical
incident but basically means they can't
operate as normal because of the
pressure now in England Six critical
incidents have been declared and some of
those cover places like Derbyshire
Nottingham Dorset Hampshire Hampshire
and the Isle of Wight buckinghamshire
and Staffordshire and at least 55 NHS
trusts have publicly stated they're
struggling to cope with the demand for
their services now we've also heard from
the interim president of NHS provider
saffron quadri saying that this is all
due to lack of investment over a long
period of time worn out Workforce lack
of Staffing she's saying that there
should be more investment in public
health and prevention that would stop
people from needing the NHS services and
Emergency Care in the first place okay
Malena thank you very much for that well
joining us now is Matthew Taylor chief
executive of the NHS Confederation good
morning to Matthew Taylor thank you very
much for being with us so that figure
that Dr Adrian ball mentioned of up to
500 people dying each week as a result
of delays in their care is that accurate
do you think
well I don't think anyone knows exactly
what that figure would be but there's no
question that when the NHS is under the
kind of pressure
that we're under right now that there
are consequences in terms of harms and
risks for patients and the fundamental
issue here is that we are still as a
Health Service in a position of
fragility
and it's important to say we don't
always have winter crisis there was a
time uh when we'd have sustained
investment over several years you know
over a decade ago when when it was not
usual to have a winter crisis in the NHS
but then we have the 10 years of
austerity that meant we went into covert
in a fragile state and that meant
covered hit us harder our Health Service
and other health services it meant that
for example we had a bigger increase in
people uh waiting for
so we went into this winter knowing
we're in a fragile state I don't think
anyone was under under any Illusions
um that
that would be difficult if you then get
what we've seen which is a huge growth
in flu
and people who are afraid or vulnerable
in hospital with flu and also it's the
impact that the flu has our own Staffing
then I'm afraid you get to the situation
we're in which is that most parts of the
Health Service and you know we focus on
hospitals but this is true of Mental
Health Services Community Services
Primary Care uh are under almost
unbearable strain and that does mean
that we're not able to provide services
as usual we have to focus all our
energies on the most urgent and uh uh
and intense uh needs and that's why
you're seeing the Declaration of
critical incidences in so many places
are you saying that those years of
austerity have essentially broken the
NHS
I don't think there's much doubt about
that we had half as much growth in
health spending as we you know Health
economists around the world when they
look at a country library with aging
population we'll say that we need growth
of around four percent a year and we had
growth of around two percent a year for
a decade and that meant we went into the
covert crisis
30 40 billion pounds less spending than
uh other comparative countries we went
in with a hundred thousand vacancies we
went in with very low Capital spending
so they don't have the buildings which
have the equipment that we need one of
us productive as we could be and I think
the really difficult thing is this today
what I'd like to say is this that you
know during covid
we absolutely said didn't we that we
wanted to learn the lessons from covid
when we saw the way that the Health
Service responded but also the way in
which the Health Service had to stop
doing almost everything else
and we wanted to learn those lessons but
yet we've gone into this winter in an
even greater sense with an even greater
degree of fragility than we went into
covet and we can see the consequences
so what we have to do you know this
winter is going to be extremely
difficult what we have to do is do
everything we can to try to minimize
harms and risks this winter and one of
the things that is vital is that as
ministers return to their desks we do
need to see a resolution to the
industrial action that threatens four
more days of strike action in January
and then when we have got through the
winter because in the end the NHS will
get through even if we have to get
through in ways which are very very
difficult for us and for patients and
for the public then we've got to have a
conversation about what we need to do to
not go into next winter in the same
position of fragility that we've gone
into this one
I mean how does the Industrial action
get resolved though because you'll know
that while it's about conditions a lot
part of it is also about pay and the
argument of course is that if you pay
staff more then you don't have enough
money for other parts of the service
well we need leadership you know I
understand the government's position
um limits on public spending worries
around inflation I absolutely understand
the trade Union's position which is
around the fact that their members have
taken real pay cuts that we have a
crisis in recruitment retention and
motivation Health Service over 130 000
vacancies so in a sense I understand why
both sides would say well we're not
going to move but this is why we need
leadership we need to look at what's
unfolding on the health service today we
need to recognize that January is the
toughest month for the Health Service
and and government needs to be willing
to negotiate uh in the right spirit and
trade unions need to be and willing to
enter into those negotiations because to
put four days of industrial action on
top of what you're hearing about today
then we were absolutely increase those
risks and harms to patients there is no
question and so we need people to be Pro
prep we need politicians the trade
unions to be pragmatic to be creative to
find a way through this not to Heap
extra pressures on a system that is
hardly coping right now okay so what was
that pragmatism look like there Matthew
do you want politicians to negotiate
over pay you you pointedly didn't
mention pay when you talked about
negotiating and do you want to see trade
unions bring down some of their pay
demands
well look this is the way negotiation
works both sides have got a starting
point
um but it does look at the moment as
though the the the the reason we can't
make any progress at all is that the
government will not negotiate about pay
and as long as the government refuses to
negotiate about pay I don't see the
trade unions entering into negotiation
now clearly when the trade unions enter
into negotiation it's a negotiation they
move from their starting point that's
how it works but at the moment there's
no conversation going on people are
adopting fixed positions and as long as
they adopt those fixed positions we
continue to walk into four days of
industrial action now you know your
report was vividly described the
pressures were under now January is out
of this month the idea that we can then
take two days of nurses strikes two days
of ambulance down strike on top of all
of this without there being major
implications for patients well you know
it's it it's a fantasy there will be
more harm there will be more risk
I mean what's it going to look like then
after those extra four days of
industrial election this month as the
services facing the winter pressures
well it will look different in different
places and we will once again have to
ask the public
to support us so in the last ambulance
dispute we saw a significant reduction
in 999 calls now we're grateful to the
public for doing that but whilst It's
always important that the public use the
Health Service in the right way if you
are worried about your health then use
one one use the NHS website use Primary
Care only ring 999 if you have a
life-threatening emergency the problem
is as we saw during covert that if
people stop using the Health Service
because they think it's not there and
there's reports today in Scotland about
this
uh then all that happens is that those
illnesses worse and and that we build up
more pressures for the future so the
situation we're in now where it's
difficult for all the NHS to cope where
so many parts of it having to declare
critical incidents we're not able to
provide the range of services well
that's a problem here and now for people
who are having operations uh canceled
waiting for ambulances but it's also a
problem for the future because it means
that we as a population become sicker
and that drives future pressures
so look the the government has provided
extra money to help get people out of
hospital because as you know one of the
issues with God is over 10 000 patients
in hospital who don't need to be there
but that money was announced late it was
distributed even later and so it's not
been able to make much difference this
year
what we've got to do when we've got
through this winter somehow is we've got
to think about how we invest money and
how we do things differently so that we
don't enter next winter in the same
position of fragility and that's what I
would say to people help us to get
through these difficult times but also
keep pressure on the government to act
in ways which which mean that we don't
have to feel this way this time next
year
so look new year new week New Start
what's your message to the health
secretary answer the leaders of the
unions to try and get this thing
resolved because no one wants to see
those strikes take place again in a
couple of weeks time
I think I want to say this is an
extraordinary time I I speak to NHS
leaders you know just about every day
and a lot of them if not most of them
say that this is the toughest winter
they've dealt with
we cannot go on like this we can't be
sitting here next year saying well this
is even tougher than last year
so we need with the support of the
public and others to get through this
difficult time and I call on the trade
unions and government to find a way of
getting through this industrial stopping
this industrial action taking place
but then we've got not we mustn't get
used to this you know we mustn't be in a
situation we we somehow accept that the
NHS being in this kind of position of
critical incidence crisis in winter is
inevitable in the country as rich as
ours when the Health Service with the
strengths that we've got you know if we
have the resources we can do remarkable
things as we showed during covert as
we've shown to the vaccination program
you know one of the sad things about the
kinds of pressures we're under now is
that we're not able to make the progress
we did make
before the winter in reducing the number
of people wasting a long time for
operations in accelerating our
diagnostic services so the Health
Service can do the job if it's given the
resources and the sport to do so
but at the moment
the fundamental capacity issues are in
danger of getting worse as I said we
went into covert with 100 000 plus
vacancies we've now got 130 000 plus
vacancies so what we need is a national
plan once we've got through the worst of
this winter and our national plan geared
towards that absolute commitment that we
will enter next winter in a in a more in
a more resilient state
okay Matthew Taylor chief executive NHS
Confederation thanks for your time this
morning thank you with us
now of course the crisis in the NHS
dominates the newspapers this morning
this is the front page of the Daily
Mirror quoting the head of the Royal
College of emergency medicine saying
that delays could lead to 500 deaths a
week that warning from Dr Adrian Boyle
is also the front page lead of the Daily
Express and for the Times which talks
about staff shortages surgery backlogs
flu and covid all contributing to the
crisis now the guardian predicts that
NHS strikes could continue for months
with staff facing real terms pay it cuts
off that's the eye reports that 70 of
conservative voters think the party has
mismanaged the Health Service while the
Daily Mail calls it a triple New Year
headache for Rishi sunak throwing in
migrant Crossings and rail strikes
The Daily Telegraph reports that the
Prime Minister has shelved plans for an
overhaul of the child care system
they've also got the NHS story beneath
the fold the sun reports on the
publication of Prince Harry's book and
the Stars Headliners barking mad which
is a story about councils spending
millions of pounds on trees some of
which die because they're not planted
properly
now in other news this morning the mayor
of Kiev Vitale Klitschko says that
another night of drone attacks across
the city of course power outages
meanwhile across the border in Russia
the governor of briansk said that
Ukrainian drones have damaged a power
supply facility overnight cutting off
electricity
let's bring it usually who's joining us
from the Ukrainian Capital cave so good
morning to you so just tell us what's
been the situation there overnight with
these uh strikes on infrastructure
mm-hmm yeah good morning Kamali I mean
after just before midnight air raid
siren sounded and then shortly after
less than 30 minutes after there was one
loud explosion and Then followed by a
series of smaller blasts that could be
heard over the next few hours and now
today they're saying that 20 aerial
targets were were struck overnight and
the mayor has actually put out just now
that a 19 year old was wounded in the
northeastern part of the of the capital
after
a damaged drone you know fell and and
hit him and this is this is two days now
of a Relentless bombardment by by Russia
this has come after Putin gave a nine
minute New Year dress on Saturday on New
Year's Eve saying accusing the west of
lying uh and provoking Moscow to launch
this special military operation in
Ukraine and now ukrainians are starring
the first two days of the year New
Year's Eve saw 20 missiles according to
Air Force to the Air Force launched into
Ukraine 12 of them were intercepted one
person killed here in the capital and
just two days prior 69 missiles the Air
Force said were launched into country 54
of those were intercepted and some of
those hit homes in Kiev this this is a
very strong message from Moscow coming
into the new year that the campaign here
in Ukraine will not end
okay for now thank you
all right let's take a little look at
some other stories that are making news
this morning and this week is going to
see more strikes across the rail network
thousands of workers represented by the
rmt going to take part in two 48-hour
walkouts affecting Journeys from Tuesday
until Saturday train drivers represented
by the aslef union will also be on
strike on Thursday and the West Coast
main line is closed north of Carlisle
because of flooding
more than a third of adults in the UK
would find it's difficult or impossible
to cover a 20 pound increase in their
monthly spend research from the charity
citizens advice also found that around 3
and 10 are losing sleep at least once a
week because of worry about their
finances
and the growing number of people are
said to be resorting to DIY medical
treatment because they can't get a
face-to-face appointment with their GP a
survey commissioned by the lib Dems
found that one in four adults tried and
failed to get a consultation in 2022.
all right time for a look at the day's
weather in the Met Office has issued a
warning for ice in Scotland Northern
Ireland in the north of England more to
come warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it will be mainly dry and settled today
but it will be colder than recently and
there's rain heading in on Tuesday it'll
be a dry start apart from some mainly
Coastal showers but it'll be chilly
where the frosts to the North and the
West there'll be some freezing fog and
some Icy stretches the morning will stay
mostly fine and dry although a few
showers will continue in the Northwest
and near Channel coasts but early fog
will linger in some places it will be
colder for most with light winds but it
should feel Pleasant enough the
afternoon will bring not much change but
the west of Ireland will see the wind
picking up ahead of evening rain Island
Northern Ireland and Northern Britain
and Northwestern Britain will turn wet
and windy overnight
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
let's get more now on our top story the
crisis in the NHS doctors warn that
hundreds of people are dying every week
because of pressure on the service Sky
News has learned that six critical
incidents are currently in place across
NHS trusts in England meaning they can't
function as usual due to the pressure
they're facing these critical incidents
cover not Derbyshire Nottingham Dorset
Hampshire the Isle of Wight
buckinghamshire and Staffordshire and at
least 55 NHS trusts have publicly stated
that they are struggling to cope with
the demand for their services
well joining us now is Dr omker sahota a
GP and labor member of the London
assembly a doctor oncasota good to have
you with us and good morning to you so
just describe the pressures that you and
your colleagues are facing
look good morning we've heard as you've
heard that the 55 cluster under special
distress general Practice in the island
Services have been under unprecedented
pressure
um the NHS is in a state of Crisis and
this is not just winter right the winter
of course we're the worst with a huge
rise in cases of flu and uh and cobit
but also this is a 12-month crisis in
the NHS and we need to do something
about this
uh and you say do something about this
what needs to be done well look first of
all I I think we need to know that this
has been a result of political decisions
taken over many many years and over the
last 12 years particularly and we need
to sit down and really say how can you
solve the nhsl and that's needs a a
government who is prepared to invest
money in the NHS but also to talk to the
to the professionals to see what's
demoralizing them what's their pressures
and to for the second state for health
to take responsibility and talk to the
nurses and doctors who in the front line
now we know there's of course pressures
on all parts of the service but I wonder
about doctors specifically there's often
talk about doctors doing a seven day
work week and that's often been rejected
I mean why is that wouldn't that
alleviate some of the pressure
well I look at the doctors do work all
the time and and I think that even talk
to the human beings they can only do
certain number of hours but I mean I
know for example in hospitals where
shifts where I should have four doctors
they only have one doctor covering their
shift we have different practice which
is together we have a vacancy from like
20 000 GPS so doctors in this country
and a hundred thousand nurses so this
huge vacancy reads and doctors are and
nurses can only work set number of hours
within their safety limits we limit the
number of hours an airline pilot will
fly we're limited number of hours which
a uh a lot of driver will drive but why
do we think the doctor's gonna work
seven days a week 24 hours
so doctors shouldn't work extra hours
that's what you're saying
I think doctors who are already working
extra hours how many hours can they work
is it the limits right I think doctors
already working 50 60 hours right okay
all the GP surgery has been really open
for uh from 8 00 am to 6 30 P.M Monday
to Friday but there's certain GPS are
the ones who are providing out of our
service in the in the weekend and the
evenings those doctors aren't coming
they asked doctors aren't just to
reserve for evenings these doctors also
worked in the daytime also so doctors
are doing extra shift over the weekend a
couple weekends out of our services so I
think they're really working very hard
you know that Junior doctors are going
to be balloting in a couple of weeks
time about their strike action would you
support your Junior colleagues going out
on strike at a time like this
I never sport uh a government not
talking to the profession to the
Frontline doctors and nurses it was a
sector's date who refused to talk to the
nurses why is it that doctors and nurses
whose job is to look after the second
health and and then people in health are
having to take strike action what is
happening in the system that's forcing
these people to take this industrial
action and I think the answer is that
this government which doesn't listen to
them it's only in those circumstances
the professionals have been pushed to
have and what is this strike actually
all about it's about patient safety if
they aren't that doctors and nurses on
the awards they're saying to the public
we can't provide a service that is
required of us and that's being honesty
with the with the public and we've only
heard yesterday that 500 people are
dying
unnecessarily every week to do these
waiting times what does it mean by the
system the public this nervous and the
government needs to react to it
yeah and with all due respect to Dr so
my question was specifically about your
Junior doctor colleagues who are going
to ballot for strike action in the next
couple of weeks and my question was
would you support Junior doctors walking
out at a time like this for the Health
Service
I support unit doctors in raising their
concerns and I support these doctors and
the government to sit down I'm not going
to say oh criticize my colleagues for
raising the voice of concern to the
government I'm not going to criticize it
for that but I'm sure these decisions
can be prevented the government can sit
down with the doctors and nurses and
they can prevent this strike action
okay Dr ankerts so to appreciate your
time this morning so thank you for being
with us thank you much thank you good
morning
all right let's take a look at some
other stories that are making news this
morning and Pope Benedict the 16th will
line state from today ahead of his
funeral on Thursday Benedict was the
first pope to resign in over six
centuries which means that his funeral
will be different from many previous for
a Catholic leader in that it will be led
by his successor now an aid to the pope
claimed that Benedict's final words were
Lord I love you
Croatia has started the New Year by
officially adopting the Euro as its
currency the nation joined the European
Union nearly a decade ago but had to
wait until now to qualify as a Eurozone
country from midnight on New Year's Eve
Croatia also entered the Schengen Zone
meaning no more border ID checks and
free movement between the 27 member
states
now four people have died in a mid-air
helicopter crash in Australia with a
further three seriously injured police
confirmed that the two aircraft collided
near the Sea World Resort on the Gold
Coast on Monday afternoon investigators
are now looking at the incident
now to perhaps the greatest footballer
who ever played the game pele's body is
going to line States at the stadium
Santos Stadium where he played for
almost his entire career and scored some
of his most memorable goals Jackie
beltrell has more from Brazil just a few
hours from now uh the doors behind me at
the Villa belmira Stadium the Santos
football stadium will open allowing the
fans who've queued overnight to walk in
and file past the coffin of the man they
call King Pele he's going to be lying
almost in State uh here on the football
pitch where he played all of his
football from a 15 year old boy right up
to when he went to the states and
retired he will stay here at the
football stadium for 24 hours before the
coffin will be taken through the streets
of Santos his career here lasted 19
Seasons he won 26 titles and lots of big
clubs in Europe were desperate to sign
him particularly after that 1958 World
Cup win when as a teenager he just the
World by its storm but they couldn't
sign him United tried Juventus tried
Inter Milan tried but the Brazilian
government declared him an official
national treasure that could never be
exported out of the country he is so
loved here in Brazil and adored here in
Santos it's going to be a very emotional
day
Jackie Bell trial reporting now
Australia is reviewing its visa and
immigration system as it tries to
rapidly increase its Workforce ever
since the country shut its borders due
to covert there haven't been enough
people to fill the jobs needed to keep
the economy growing Nicole Johnston
reports now from Sydney
Australia is in the grip of a severe
worker shortage
sales of its most iconic sight
desperate demand for chefs bartenders
Baristas the list goes on
when covert struck foreigners fled now
Australia wants them back up for grabs
500 pounds sign-on bonuses
we've got a couple of fine dining
restaurants and we can't open certain
days because we just don't have enough
staff and that's across the industry
it's it's like that competition for
talent is tight and poaching staff is
Rife hello there ladies I've got two
espresso martinis
good job here oh there's jobs everywhere
up and down the coast everyone is crying
out for staff at the moment what about
the pain the pay is amazing yeah
compared to at home there is a big
difference
the difference is double
hundreds of miles from Sydney fruit
picking pays up to 300 pounds a day but
there's no one to do it these trees
should have been picked about
three months ago couldn't get enough
fruit Pickers so we just left them on
the trees and now they just fallen off
on the ground
a year of work 140
000 pounds of fruit left to rot
unemployment is at its lowest level in
nearly 50 years
so the government is planning to
overhaul the entire Visa system and
allow in an extra 35
000 permanent migrants
one in three businesses are desperate
for staff the country needs hundreds of
thousands of new workers fast without
them Australia won't be able to keep up
the extraordinary growth of its economy
also wanted skilled labor people to fix
cars build houses and take jobs in mines
hospitals and schools
no regrets here swapping North Yorkshire
for the Sydney summer
I went to see my friends family which
was absolutely great but then it kind of
put the nail in the coffin for me it was
just the life isn't as good as here at
all in what way so just the aspect the
cost to live in it's just going through
the roof at the minute you can see
people aren't that happier and even now
there's more and more of my friends what
are actually migrating travel in Asia
and coming to Australia for this life
for the beach the everything
strong wages countless jobs a healthy
economy all that's missing are the
workers
Nicole Johnston Sky News Sydney
time for a look through the mornings and
newspapers and with us to review them as
the editor of the big issue Paul McNamee
and the broadcaster Thomas copelander
but before we hear from them let's take
a look through the front pages I'll
start with the front page of the Daily
Mirror which quotes the head of the
Royal College of emergency medicine
who's the delays in care could be
killing 500 patients a week that warning
from Dr Boyle also makes the front page
of the Daily Express the times also
makes it their front page story and they
mentioned the staff shortages surgery
backlogs flu and covid all contributing
to the crisis the service is facing the
guardian predicts that NHS strikes could
continue with the months with staff
facing real terms pay cuts the eye
reports that 73 of conservative voters
think the party has mismanaged the
Health Service
of the Daily Mail calls it a triple New
Year headache from Richie sunac throwing
in migrant Crossing and rail strikes too
the telegraph reports that the Prime
Minister has shelved plans for an
overhaul of the child care system and
they've got the NHS story on the front
page two the sun reports on the
publication of Prince Harry's new book
while the star's headline is barking mad
a story about Council spending millions
of pounds on trees some of which die
because they haven't been planted
properly
all right let's bring our guests in
Thomas and Paul guys thanks for being
with us again let's go inside the papers
now and we're going to start with you
Thomas you've picked out this story page
six of the Guardian about Extinction
Rebellion talk to us about that this
isn't quite a few of the papers as well
Extinction Rebellion a group made famous
for you know it's really disruptive
forms of protest you'll remember people
gluing themselves to the gates of
Buckingham Palace lots of extensive
disruption in Piccadilly Circus Oxford
Circus Bank headquarters and newspapers
being you know paint and Windows Windows
being smashed that's what made this
group famous they've issued a statement
yesterday entitled we quit saying that
it wants to move away from that highly
disruptive form of protest brilliant
quote quote they want to prioritize
attendance over arrest and relationships
over roadblocks and they had met in the
piece in the statement that's a
controversial move especially with the
people who supported and have supported
Extinction Rebellion precisely because
it was engaged in that kind of highly
disruptive protest a lot of young people
can't help but feeling there's probably
a lot of politics underneath the surface
here Extinction Rebellion always
provided itself on being a decentralized
organization but that's not to say and
it's always the case that there's great
and very Dynamic power struggles going
on here you also feel as if you know is
this an organization that's been
outflanked by the likes of just stop oil
another similar protest group that's
made famous over the last couple of
months by throwing two and at works of
art and across the UK
um it feels a little bit like what
Extinction Rebellion is trying to do
here is just move themselves into being
a much more mainstream organization they
talk about building relationships inside
and outside par that feels like it's an
organization that once it moves itself
into the mainstream these kind of the
kind of action in which it was engaged
was always a bit of a trade-off and they
you know you were trading in the
headlines that you gained the extra
publicity more people talking about
these issues of climate a change and in
exchange you annoyed a certain number of
people I wonder whether Extinction
Rebellion now feels it's got to Tipping
Point of where you know the balance is
no longer in its favor this article
quotes say uh you golf Paul that says
that the organization is disliked by
more people than it is liked is this a
move towards trying to become a much
more mainstream player aware of the fact
that new organizations like just stop
oil there will always be a new
organization to outflank where you're
standing and they want a more permanent
position interestingly the adjustable
Landing State Britain which I believe is
spin-offs of Extinction Rebellion have
not said they're going to stop their
direct action so that will continue so
it is a fascinating a movie uh Thomas
and thanks for bringing us that Paul
let's go to you and you've picked up
this story also in the guardian as well
about bus fares and on the face of it a
two pound sort of flat fee for bus fares
sounds great but there might be a
wrinkle in that
yeah very much and and I think um boss
Provost and public transport invasion is
one of the the quiet crises across Brit
um at the moment this story related to a
three-month
walleye of 60 million money to cut boss
fares at two pounds as you say across
about four and a half thousand
which is great A lot of them in rural
South West and Northeast where we're
both provision is not great
however the warning comes from campaign
for better transport that says once this
Runs Out
um and it will run out around the same
time as additional provision to help
public transport post covet that there
is a risk of up to 20 of bus services
going away of operation and um be no
longer there for people
and I think this is a this is a real
um real problem because bus services
particularly in places of deprivation
um and in rural areas where there's not
always wealth investment are essential
not just for key workers who frequently
need to use them but for pensioners or
people who don't necessarily have a
private transport and when that comes
away it stops
um the engines of Commerce working in
those areas and also just being able to
guess
if I guess you get the big big reaction
and there's a possibility to do
something about it if you look at Andy
Burnham in Greater Manchester bringing
some Services back into public ownership
or in development where if you're under
21 and under you get free bus
uh yes that things can be done if
there's a will but again this just feels
like a lack of proper joint up thinking
from Westminster it's good that they've
got this but they haven't thought a
little farther down the road literally
literally all right uh Thomas let's
let's turn to you now and you've got
this story here in the uh Express about
Amazon and I'll let you give us all the
detail of this I don't think viewers
will be very surprised when they hear
what you've got to say
well that's right it's a typically
depressing unpredictable story so Amazon
launched Amazon aware earlier on in the
year a whole line of everyday products
that they said would be the eco-friendly
choice you can just about see the logo
there on your screen they've replaced
the A and aware with a leaf which is a
classic move but it's plagued by many of
the same issues that we see in the way
that online shopping works much more
broadly a Telegraph and investigation
find that items were still wrapped in
single-use plastic they were being
imported from all over the world now
Amazon says that it does carbon
offsetting for all of these products
that typically means donating or or
finding financially supporting
initiatives elsewhere to try to offset
some of that carbon used planting trees
cleaning up the oceans Etc the big
headline I suppose in here in most of
these papers is the green party peer
Jenny Jones calling this green washing
on a grotesque scale and saying that
this carbon off setting doesn't work now
to be fair to Amazon it's a fairly
limited investigation then this is a new
line of products but here's a New Year's
resolution maybe for consumers that want
to engage in a more eco-friendly Choice
you've got to look at the fine print if
you want to make these decisions then
just make sure that the people that
you're going to to try to get these
eco-friendly choices are actually you
know seeing this through all the way
down the supply chain that's the major
problem with Amazon there's potential
here and clearly they understand the
fact and or at least to a certain extent
capitalizing monetarily on the fact that
people want to go for these more
eco-friendly choices but I think
consumers are smart as well and they're
cotton on pretty quickly when they find
that these initiatives actually don't
work and they realize the places that
they want to go to or don't want to go
to for an eco-friendly Choice So
eventually I think Amazon will need to
iron out all of these Kinks consumers
won't be you know they won't have the
world pulled over their eyes for that
much longer there's your New Year's
resolution look at the fine print
absolutely right always uh worth looking
at the fine print if you can face it and
sticking with the sort of theme uh Paul
your story here in the Daily Telegraph
is gonna bloke who is who's a general
genuine Eco Champion tell us about this
yeah this is
the story for the new year actually
there's been a lot of negative stories
but this is a good story
um uh and I I like to also because it's
from uh part of the world that I know
well in North Antrim it's a fellow
called Stuart Hood who has planted 20
000 trees twenty thousand of them on a
22 Acre Site just outside Antrim uh he's
put in some native Beach Oak and he's
then going to put in some paint
I guess it doesn't have to do it it's
got a bit of a grunt to do it but it's a
good thing that there are people who are
trying to
um trying to plant trees when we need as
many trees as we can and also bring in a
little biodiversity because it also says
that his son has put some beehives in
the area and they're looking to keep
some Wetland within the area as well so
there are these pockets of positivity of
people doing the right thing and trying
to make the world better for all of us
I let's hope that it's not just in in
North Antrim outside of Android town but
across the rest of Britain but for now I
am celebrating Sunday Northern Ireland
doing something well yeah and well worth
celebrating and I'm sure it is happening
in other areas but it's really good to
see that someone is planting trees and
bringing back these kind of uh areas
good for the Wildlife and good for us
too right Thomas Paul thanks both very
much